el embarazo es el periodo durante el
cual se desarrolla su bebé dentro del
útero suele durar unas 40 semanas
contadas a partir del primer día de la
última menstruación
estas 40 semanas se dividen en tres
segmentos llamados trimestres el segundo
trimestre se extiende desde la semana 14
hasta el final de la semana 27 al
principio del segundo trimestre su bebé
ahora llamado feto mide unos cinco
centímetros desde la cabeza hasta las
nalgas
alrededor de este momento los párpados
de su bebé se cierran y los órganos
sexuales comienzan a formarse en el
exterior del cuerpo
en la décimo sexta semana su bebé crece
y llega a medir unos 12 centímetros de
largo en la cabeza comienza a aparecer
pelo fino llamado lanugo y la boca
comienza a hacer movimientos de succión
a las 20 semanas su bebé puede oír y
tragar
[Música]
Además está más activo
puede sentirlo como ondas en el bajo
vientre
A mediados de este trimestre es posible
que le realicen una ecografía para
controlar el movimiento la frecuencia
cardíaca y el tamaño de su bebé a veces
el sexo del bebé puede ser visible
a las 24 semanas los pulmones están
formados pero no están preparados para
funcionar fuera del útero
se puede escuchar el latido del corazón
con un estetoscopio
al final del segundo trimestre su bebé
ha aumentado de peso y mide unos 30
centímetros de la cabeza a las nalgas
es posible que se sienta mejor Durante
este trimestre que como se sintió
Durante los tres primeros meses algunos
de los cambios que puede notar incluyen
menos náuseas y fatiga
piel más oscura alrededor de los pezones
una línea oscura en la piel desde el
ombligo hasta la ingle llamada línea
negra
estrías en el vientre los pechos los
muslos o las nalgas hinchazón en la cara
los dedos y los tobillos y puedes sentir
más el movimiento de su bebé
Si tiene alguna pregunta sobre el
desarrollo de su bebé o le preocupa Cómo
se siente hable con su proveedor de
atención médica